I did check EWG before using the regular salary, but didn't find it. I thought I've read that if it's on either list, it's somewhere in between possibly safe. Yes, that's correct.
In the salary juice book, it says regular is fine if washed well. I would dare do it again and remember to that, you know, remember these fields that might be sprayed.
It's a tractor driving down the field and they have the scraping apparatus in the back that is sprayed.
And then they turn a quarter at the end of the field and you think the product at those quarters probably get like four times the dose, you know, when it's when they don't turn off the spray or turn the corner.
You know what I mean? It can be some weird like that that you just got a, you know, a stalk of salary that was, you know, infested. That's the right terminology with some sort of toxin.
And if you went to the same store about another stock in the next day, you know, if they had gone through it that fast, it could be completely a different dose.
I mean, there's no way that unless you have your own organic chemistry lab that you're going to be able to test, you know, each piece of food that you're going to, you know, cook for your family to see the doses of glyphosate or whatever you're looking for in that.
So it's you, you're kind of hit miss and the truth is you can be exposed to this stuff with organic stuff. There's cross contamination.
Sometimes these fields are very far apart that they're contaminated with or it could be something completely different than it was contaminated with who knows or it could not, maybe not even be the salary itself.
So, oh, there's another thing too. You can actually have antibodies to salary. So running the array Syrex array 10.
I've had people that have antibodies to salary. So they're going to have an inflammatory spot response by eating salary, whether it's organic or not organic.
So that's a possibility or you could just had, you know, an inflammatory response because it's something else that was going on in your gut.
You know, there's a lot of possibilities.
We don't want to completely jump to the conclusions that we were talking about. So we just don't know everything.
As far as the benefits of salary juice, yeah, there can be benefits to juicing different vegetables.
But they just be careful going on a specific diet that's restricted other foods and other nutrients to your better off getting as many different foods and food groups in your system is as possible.
That's going to be the best thing to support your gut biome and the rest of your biome is to have a variety of different foods.